what up space fam goes in here from
anime opera and i'm extremely excited
for this video in which i'll give
important updates about
seven deadly sins the final season the
final movie the new ending which looks
like the ending we all wanted so make
sure to stay tuned for that
if you do enjoy seeing seven deadly sins
videos on this channel and want to keep
them coming the best thing you could do
is
channel the one within and smash that
like button until it's blue
if you haven't make this the video
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications
or you will miss future seven deadly
sins videos and updates and while you
wait for the next video to drop feel
free to check out
our giant seven deadly sins playlist
where we have videos on all the sins
commandments the sacred treasures and
much more link to that is in the
description
before we get into it a quick thank you
to alchemy stars for sponsoring this
video
alchemy stars is a brand new line
strategy rpg that launches this summer
set in the beautiful anime inspired
world of astra
a bewitching land of science and magic
where light and dark
clash alchemy stars feature stunning
graphics and amazing characters who were
brought to life through the work
of 150 remarkable illustrators and manga
artists but the thing that really makes
alchemy stars stand out from the rest is
its revolutionary
line strategy rpg system basically the
way you line up your characters on the
battlefield determines how strong and
effective your attack combos will be
so there is a lot of strategy involved
here this line strategy rpg system is so
unique and so rewarding once you really
start taking advantage of it and i
personally haven't played anything quite
like it before
it is extremely cool check it out for
yourself just click the top link in the
description to start playing for
free since this is a brand new game this
is the perfect time to start playing
and get a leg up on the competition
alchemy stars is actually organizing a
contest to see
who can get the highest combo in the
game so if you want to enter and win
awesome prizes
link to that is also in the description
down below now without further ado
let's jump into it spoilers and all
before we jump into this new ending
which we'll receive in the form of the
new seven deadly sins movie cursed by
light
let me just give some updates to the
seven deadly sins fans wondering
when everything is supposed to be
released the final season of the seven
deadly sins anime is supposed to drop on
netflix on june 28th
2021 and there's going to be plenty to
love in this season that netflix dubbed
dragon's judgment we'll get to see some
amazing power upgrades and hype moments
like bon after purgatory ameliotis
upgrade a king upgrade an escanor power
upgrade and so on we'll get to see most
of our favorite ships set sail into the
sunset with a happy ending
and the birth of the next generation
including tristan the son of meliotis
and elizabeth what i wasn't crazy about
though with the seven deadly sins ending
and again here's my second spoiler
warning if you're not caught up with the
manga
is how the battle they chose to end it
off was the battle against kath
i get that it sort of makes sense to end
off with a focus on arthur since we're
dealing with arthurian legend here
but it felt sort of anti-climactic after
the epic fight against the demon king
where all
seven sins were present a fight that was
being set up from the beginning of the
series
esquinor wasn't present during the cath
fight because he sacrificed himself in
the previous
fight which also felt weird not having a
sin present and it just felt like the
cath part seemed out of place in
relation to the rest of the story
and most of us wanted to see the sins
take on someone like the supreme deity
next
which would have made more sense after
the demon king especially since the
supreme deity was kind of in the
background of the story the entire time
with characters referring to her every
so often well
here's where the movie cursed by light
comes in
and as the name of the movie suggests i
think you can start to get a sense
of what it's actually about it hasn't
been released yet but should premiere
on july 2nd 2021 in japan so only a few
days after the final season drops on
netflix and i just want to give credit
to netflix for actually dropping the
final season within a more reasonable
time span this time around
rather than keeping it in netflix jail
for several months
it does seem like they've been listening
to anime fans and i hope that continues
so as i mentioned this movie is not out
yet but from the trailer details which
i'll go over in a bit
it looks very promising and it appears
to contain most if not
all of what we have wanted from the
ending of the seven deadly sins
it seems to be in between the time skip
aka pre the seven deadly sins having
kids
because we definitely don't see any of
the kids in the trailers but we do see
king and deanne getting married
which will be a great moment for us to
watch so this shouldn't be considered a
sequel that continues where the manga
left off but more like an extended
more detailed ending filling in some of
the gaps a new threat pops up in the
form of dahlia
the second fairy king who wants to make
the sins pay for ruining the holy war
he's accompanied by dabuzu the master
craftsman of the giants
i love that they are actually including
dahlia because he's been one of those
characters that's been mentioned in the
manga but i never really expected to see
him so the fact that they made use of
him is very exciting
and more importantly as i'll get into in
a little bit it is revealed in the
second trailer that the supreme deity
will show up as well to confront the
sins so not only do we get the fight
against the supreme deity that we wanted
we get the second
fairy king thrown in for good measure
obviously it'll also matter how they
handle the fights and how satisfying
they are but the setup here has
so much potential what i also love to
see from the trailer is meliotis and
zeldris
fighting side by side they're two of my
favorite brothers in anime and i
love to see them on the same side this
time defending the demon world
in the first trailer we also saw king in
his king of rock form
merlin with her mouth covered so we
don't see the burn marks she got from
escanor in this first trailer and
king arthur will make an appearance too
as we see him
crying in the trailer but i do think the
main focus
is going to be on our seven deadly sins
which is exactly what we want from this
series
i'm more interested in the second
trailer though we get a better sense of
dahlia's powers
which seem to be fire based i've even
heard theories that he's inherited
sunshine but that's probably a stretch
at this point
it is in this trailer that will see the
supreme deity
and props to how they reveal the supreme
deity too unless you pause at the
perfect time
you will easily miss her since light
surrounds her as soon as she appears in
the trailer engulfing the whole screen
if you do pause it at just the right
time though you could see her with her
head covered in light as usual and we
see vaughn
king gother and diane confronting her
notably meliotis and elizabeth aren't
there but it's just one scene and they
may well get the chance to confront her
afterwards which is my hope
she is more so their personalized
villain anyways so i think it would be
more satisfying for their character arcs
if they play a crucial role in defeating
her too just as they did with the demon
king this time we straight up see the
burn marks on merlin's mouth from her
kiss with escanor
proving that this is in fact after
escondor has passed away but
significantly we see esknore's the one
mode
now could this just be a flashback
totally but it might also suggest that
in some way escanor may return if only
for a limited time for this battle
how that would work i'm not sure however
is it out of the realm of possibility
for a shonen series heavily influenced
by dragon ball z
and that includes magical powers i don't
think so it at least gives me hope that
escanor's character in one way or
another
may play an important role in this fight
and honestly it wouldn't be the seven
deadly sins without him but the sixth
deadly sins which is more so what the
fight against kath
was so i'm hoping this flash of eskanor
in the trailer means that the movie will
give us an epic final fight
that includes eskanor to send the seven
deadly sins off right
it would be weird if any of the seven
deadly sins were missing but escond in
particular is one of my favorites so we
really need him in this movie in one way
or another
notably they do also focus on a scene
where meliotis gets attacked by his
clones not as big of a deal as the rest
of the stuff i mentioned but it just
gives you a sense of the powers they may
have to face
it could be a form of genjutsu or
illusion or it could straight up be the
ability to take control of others either
way
i am looking forward to this movie big
time because
it does have potential to be a solid new
ending for the seven deadly sins the one
we all hoped for
which finally includes the supreme deity
and maybe
even eschanor again if it doesn't
include escanor i feel like they
shouldn't even be allowed to call it the
seven deadly sins
since there would only be six of them
let me know your thoughts on all of this
do you think
eskanor will somehow help in this new
war what do you think are going to be
dalia's powers and what kind of powers
do you think the supreme deity is going
to use
and what are you most looking forward to
seeing in this movie
if you are starred for more 7 deadly
sins you can
check out the sequel four knights of the
apocalypse if you haven't the thing is
it is following different characters but
it is the same mangaka and the story is
set in the same arthurian world
if you are caught up on the four knights
of the apocalypse let us know how you're
liking it in the comments below
does it have potential to be as good as
the seven deadly sins was the biggest
issue is that we've come to love these
characters so much
they're some of my favorite characters
in all of anime so it's hard to accept
that we won't be seeing as much of
eschanor meliotis bond
and the rest anymore but such is life
anyways that is it for this one i hope
you enjoyed this seven daily sins
update video and that it helped spark
your interest in the new movie ending if
you did enjoy the video and want to keep
them coming
the best thing you could do is channel
the one within and smash
that like button until it's blue if you
haven't make this the video you
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications
or you will miss future 7 deadly sins
videos and updates
and while you wait for the final season
to drop on netflix
and for the movie to drop as well feel
free to check out our
giant seven deadly sins playlist where
we have videos on all the sins all the
commandments the sacred treasures and
much much more
it's crazy how many videos we've done on
the seven daily sins so link to that
playlist is in the description
thanks again to alchemy stars for
sponsoring this video make sure to check
it out by clicking that link in the
description and until next time see you
space cowboys
[Music]
you